y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es muy probable que cada uno de ustedes
sepa sobre la enfermedad de alzheimer es
probable que tengan algún conocido
allegado a un ser querido que padezca
esta enfermedad pero tan frecuente es
les pido un pequeño ejercicio si pueden
cerrar los ojos un momento y como si
fuese un ejercicio de yoga inspirar
y retener tres segundos el aire que yo
voy a contar
3 pueden expirar
abrir los ojos y en este lapso
cada tres segundos en algún lugar del
planeta se detecta una demencia
se calcula que actualmente hay alrededor
de 50 millones que padecen esta
enfermedad en el mundo que esto va a ser
de 80 millones en el 2030 y que en el
2050 va a pasar los 150 millones de
personas padecientes de demencia en
nuestro país en la argentina ya hay más
de 600 mil personas que padecen demencia
y cerca de 1.200.000 personas con
deterioro cognitivo
por supuesto tiene un gran impacto
sanitario si fuese la economía de un
país sería la economía número 18 del
mundo como turquía
es una enfermedad que se acerca al
trillón de dólares terminado este año es
decir que si fuese una compañía sería
más valiosa que google o que apple y
para el año 2030 se calcula que serán 2
trillones de dólares sea como fuere el
impacto de esta enfermedad generalmente
es en el seno de la propia familia
es una enfermedad de edad dependiente
una de cada diez personas después de los
60 años la padece pero se duplica cada
cinco años
esto significa que llegado a los 80
seguramente más de 1 de cada 3 va a
tener una demencia y pasados los 85 casi
dos de cada tres personas van a tener
una demencia
ha crecido mucho el número de personas
activas que caminan entre nosotros de la
séptima octava y novena década esto
explica que cada vez más tenemos
tengamos pacientes y personas que
padezcan deterioro cognitivo y demencia
es una enfermedad que luego del cáncer
es la más temida por la población
es una enfermedad que se manifiesta por
una afectación cerebral que nos va a
traer cambios en la personalidad cambios
en la memoria y va a hacer que el sujeto
ya no sea más lo que era va a cambiar su
nivel funcional
pero hoy vine aquí para darles una muy
buena noticia
una noticia de gran impacto
la noticia es que un tercio de las
demencias puede prevenirse es el primer
gran golpe contra la enfermedad el 30
por ciento de las demencias pueden
prevenirse y en realidad esta no es la
gran noticia la gran noticia es que
esto no va a ser producido por una droga
maravillosa ni de alto costo ni mediante
procedimientos cuentos ni difícil de
conseguir pero sobre todo increíblemente
no va a tener ningún efecto adverso
es realmente la que nos vuelve
protagonistas vos vos vos todos nosotros
podemos detener hoy el 30 por ciento de
las demencias una de cada tres este
descubrimiento que se hizo en finlandia
en el denominado estudio finger como el
dedo
es un estudio poblacional de gran
impacto que se basa en una intervención
múltiple sobre los hábitos de vida
hábitos saludables y también en el
control de los factores de riesgo
vascular
esto hizo que la comisión denominada the
lancet que es una comisión para la
intervención atención y prevención de
las demencias
constituyera siete factores modificables
de riesgo que todos debemos conocer y
que nos hacen protagonistas el primero
de ellos es la hipertensión arterial en
la edad media es decir que no hay que
esperar para envejecer si no se puede
actuar antes el segundo es la obesidad
también en el adulto medio el tercero es
el tabaquismo
también la baja del nivel educacional
y después también la depresión la
diabetes y también el sedentarismo
además de esto tenemos otra buena
noticia por suerte de los biomarcadores
que son las técnicas por las cuales hoy
podemos bio marcar la proteína pegajosa
del amiloide se llegó a descubrir que en
realidad la enfermedad de alzheimer
puede empezar hasta 25 años antes de los
primeros síntomas
esto amplifica el poder que tenemos
nosotros y la responsabilidad para la
prevención
permítanme ahora que nuevamente les
cuente una historia milenaria en tres
minutos nuevamente les voy a pedir que
cierren los ojos pero es para situarse
nada más en la imaginación en un
convento en una abadía esto sucedió en
cerca del año 500
esta abadía era de una orden de monjes
que era muy famosa y que abastecía a su
comunidad en las cuestiones espirituales
educacionales y religiosas muy queridos
por su comunidad en una amplia orden de
sacerdotes que tenía una gran
peculiaridad en ella se escondía el
secreto para llegar al paraíso nadie lo
sabía ya me habían pasado miles de años
pero una noche uno de los ancianos
sacerdotes agonizaba alrededor de él
estaban todos los jóvenes y los no tan
jóvenes le pidió a uno de sus allegados
que se acercara a su oído y antes de su
último suspiro le reveló el camino y el
secreto para llegar al paraíso era un
mapa eran las llaves que estaban
escondidas detrás de un guijarro en el
campanario de la misma abadía
murió se reunieron fueron
escaleras arriba encontraron el cofre
con el mapa y con las llaves de
liberaron toda la noche que iban a ser
iban a abandonar a su comunidad y
emprender un viaje de meses a caballo
siguiendo el mapa para encontrar el tan
ansiado paraíso o se iban a quedar con
los suyos
para seguir su tarea por un voto por un
solo voto de los más jóvenes ganaron
para emprender el viaje
a madrugada con la complicidad de la
oscuridad de la noche salieron y
emprendieron el viaje que duró meses
muchos murieron en el camino finalmente
frente a ellos un enorme pórtico se
abalanzaron sobre él abrieron con las
llaves y se encontraban en el mismo
patio de la abadía
que nos enseña esta historia que cada
uno de nosotros somos protagonistas de
crear nuestro propio paraíso en el
estudio finger y en otros estudios que
se están replicando similares
nosotros somos protagonistas de cambiar
conductas de hábitos saludables y de
estilos de vida y controlar los factores
de riesgo vascular para llegar a una
mejor ruta de nuestra salud cerebral
empecemos a analizar estos siete
factores y qué es lo que podemos hacer
empecemos con la educación hay estudios
que han demostrado una disminución del
riesgo de demencia en la población que
ha terminado la escuela secundaria cómo
se explica esto la educación tiene un
factor de neuroprotección está basado en
lo que se llama reserva cognitiva que se
podría explicar simplemente como una
utilización más eficiente de nuestro
cerebro con un valor de neuroprotección
también tenemos que hablar de factores
como el tabaquismo todos pensamos que el
tabaquismo es hacerle mal a nuestros
pulmones oa nuestros bronquios quizá el
temor del cáncer pero hay una gran
asociación entre tabaquismo y demencia y
deterioro cognitivo y lo mejor de ello
es que no se sabe bien por qué es salvo
dos o tres factores que si están muy
involucrados uno es la arterioesclerosis
otro es el aumento del estrés oxidativo
celular
es muy importante saber además que los
estudios demostraron que el que fuma
pero deja de fumar puede llegar también
a obtener la misma protección cognitiva
contra la demencia en las estadísticas
del que no fumo
otro factor muy importante es el
ejercicio por supuesto que todos ustedes
saben que el ejercicio va a ser una
llave eficiente contra las enfermedades
cerebrovasculares contra la hipertensión
arterial contra la obesidad es por todo
ello y por mucho más que el ejercicio se
transforma en una relación inversa con
el riesgo cognitivo y el riesgo de
demencia
el ejercicio ha demostrado un aumento de
las estructuras responsables de la
memoria inmediata a la que utilizamos
todo el día un aumento de los hipocampos
en muchos estudios hay 15 meta-análisis
estudios más amplios que demuestran la
relación entre el ejercicio físico y en
la protección cognitiva
otro de los factores muy importantes es
la estimulación cognitiva la
estimulación cognitiva ha demostrado
también ser un factor de neuroprotección
hay un estudio de tres grupos
de 10 años de de seguimiento con
entrenamientos en memoria en atención en
memoria aviso espacial que demostraron
un factor de protección de deterioro
cognitivo y demencia
otro factor muy importante y el alcance
de todos es la dieta cuál es la dieta
más relacionada con la prevención de
deterioro cognitivo y demencia la dieta
mediterránea una dieta amplia una dieta
accesible que se basa fundamentalmente
en verduras en frutas en pescado que
trata de alejarse de las harinas trata
de alejarse de los chacinados embutidos
fiambres y frituras pero que es amplia y
que también incluye pollo un poco de
carne también incluye cereales legumbres
otro factor muy importante es el control
de la hipertensión arterial
uno de cada tres personas probablemente
tenga hipertensión arterial pero después
de los 60 años casi dos de cada tres
personas tienen hipertensión arterial
hay una franja asociación entre la
hipertensión arterial y la demencia
entonces hoy eso tiene tratamiento lo
dije con el ejercicio primero lo dije
con la dieta también la dieta
mediterránea que es la que más protege a
las arterias y también con los remedios
anti hipertensivos quizá uno de los
factores más relevantes que pueda
decirles esta noche es la detección y el
control de la hipertensión arterial de
la obesidad también y también de la
diabetes son todos factores que además
generalmente están integrados el estudio
finger fue el primero que demostró que
la demencia que aún no tiene cura si
puede tener prevención que nosotros
somos protagonistas de esa prevención
el estudio finger está siendo replicado
y se ha extendido en lo que se llama el
worldwide finger es amplitud hacia el
mundo que incluye ya a japón alemania
canadá a españa y la buena noticia que
también a la argentina otros estudios
como el pointer en eeuu como él mind en
china como el zinc en singapur también
tienen el mismo núcleo de qué se trata
si cambiamos hábitos o estilos de vida
saludables y controlamos los factores de
riesgo vascular podemos llegar a tener
nuestro propio pequeño paraíso una mejor
ruta para una mejor salud cerebral
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]